[Musique]
nous amène aujourd'hui avec moi au
samsung campus samsung un campus où ils
permettent à plein de jeunes pleins de
monde d'apprendre le métier du code
comprendre ce qu'on peut faire avec car
vous avez c'est vachement intéressant
parce qu'au final
samsung a créé le samsung campus mais
c'est pas du tout pour en tirer profit
pour avoir un vivier de codeurs c'est au
delà de ça c'est intéressant c'est
vraiment vraiment vraiment passionnant
vous amène avec moi vous allez voir
trois cas plutôt cool ça commence par là
ça avance voilà bien donc on est
aujourd'hui au sam son campus avec
florent de samsung en avant de parler ça
me semble qu'en plus ça que tu peux me
dire qui tu es toi l'affluence
oui alors je me suis là c'est à quel
poste chez samsung
je suis en charge notamment de tout ce
qui est engagé en société pour saab sont
ok portée bon alors justement la rogne
et au samsung campus est ce que tu peux
me redéfinir un peu ce qu'est le samsung
campus et qu'après on expliquera comment
ça marche quoi tout ça tout ça tout ça
tout ça
l'alsacien alors le sam son campus pour
la faire courte c'est un centre de
formation il a ouvert en priorité à des
jeunes qui ne sont pas allés jusqu'au
baccalauréat qui leur propose de suivre
une formation gratuite de deux ans aux
métiers développeurs web
formation gratuite vers à turin où il
tout est mis en place par samsung pour
former cette ces jeunes c'est plutôt un
public jeune plutôt un public jeune
puisque on s'adresse à des 18 25 ans
d'accord donc effectivement il ya les
locaux ont financé également la
formation c'est pas nous qui la faisons
cette épitaphe d'accord et puis
on a mis en place un certain nombre de
modules supplémentaires par exemple est
un programme de mentorat des cours
d'anglais
l'initiation à tout ce qui est ventes et
marketing pour mieux comprendre en fait
l'environnement dans lequel ils vont
être amenés à travailler là-bas ça vas y
toi
bon alors tu perds du temps du symptôme
campus mais on est là on s aime son fils
c'est juste à côté de 9,0 à l'accueil
sur la première salle de formation
d'accord donc ça c'est une grande salle
où tout le monde bosse hockey ouais
l'idée justement c'est que tout le monde
va bosser en open space dans son projet
du coup tout est ouvert
ok du couvent registre où se trouvait
dans les eaux des cales qu'est ce qu'on
apprend on apprend à devenir développeur
web
on n'a pas tort à coder on est beaucoup
sur le front plutôt puis ensuite
derrière il ya des débouchés
extraordinaire puisque on est encore en
france en pénurie de développer
améliorer et développer son marché
français à plusieurs dizaines de
milliers vrai c'est énorme c'est énorme
donc il ya beaucoup donc c'est une
formation dans laquelle on sait qu'on va
venir valeur beaucoup beaucoup de
travail mais à la fin on peut avoir à la
fin on a un métier on a un métier
aujourd'hui nous sommes son campus a
ouvert en septembre 4 2014
d'accord donc on a déjà trois promotions
qui sont sortis et sur ces trois
promotions on en a 80 % qui ont trouvé
un emploi dans les semaines voire avant
même d'avoir fini la formation et les
20% restant eux ont fait le choix de
suivre avec une autre formation pour
viser un master d'accord et donc il ya
un emploi lorsqu'on vient où ça me
saoule campo comment ça se passe pour
pouvoir venir chez vous comment on fait
pour rentrer dans le sun tzu campus
alors j'en vois par exemple
allez je sais que le coach ça pourrait
m'intéresser je connais absolument rien
je me dis que ça paie chouette comment
je fais pour ses importants ce que tu
viens dire parce qu'effectivement pour
entrer au ca me son campus on n'a pas
besoin d'avoir fait du code avant en
fait on s'inscrit sur un site qui
s'appelle le som son campus point fr on
est ensuite invités à suivre un parcours
sur un bouc qui va nous permettre si on
n'a jamais causé de voir un petit peu
plus concrètement ce que ça si ça me
plaît
à ce moment là on continue et à
continuer ça veut dire
on va développer son premier site web de
quatre pages qu'on va venir présenter
et puis si là encore ça nous plaît
toujours et que tout se passe bien on
intègre une piscine de trois semaines où
là on est complètement con je signe de
trois semaines d'une piscine on est dans
l'immersion au fait tout à fait ça
pendant trois semaines ouais et au bout
des trois semaines si on est toujours
motivé et bien on rentre ça me semble
qu'en plus je perce à la salle de
l'équipe pédagogique
alors ok t'as plein de petites ce qu'on
appelle les bagages donc les demis
halloween où les gens peuvent travailler
tranquillement si le daaka fait en fait
prendre ce qui fausse petite collation
les japonais tout l'union comment ça se
passe en première année première année
alors elle se fait à temps plein au sein
de son campus d'accord et puis la
deuxième année par contre elle se fait
en alternance donc au rythme de une
semaine par mois au campus et les trois
autres en entreprise quel est le profil
des personnes qui viennent le but
d'identifier toi les que j'imagine qu'il
ya plein de types de personnes
différentes qui viennent mais qu'est ce
qui unit ces personnes au delà de se
dire voilà les métiers du code ça
m'intéresse alors ça c'est super
important quand même oui c'est à dire
c'est quand même moi je veux faire
coiffure mais bon j'ai pas trouvé voilà
non il ya des parcours il ya des
partants extrêmement différents par
exemple je reprends sahel
jeune femme qui s'appelle apple n est qu
il n était fleuriste au départ la gorgue
et elle adorait son métier et puis bon
elle a été amené à déménager elle a pas
d'autres trouvé d'emploi de fleuriste là
où elle avait déménagé
donc elle a pensé à se reconvertir elle
a entendu parler de tout ce qui est
écoles et elle s'est dit après tout
pourquoi pas et aujourd'hui elle a
trouvé à elle a trouvé un autre métier
qui la passionne complètement c'est ton
prénom ses bons plans c'est qu'evans
antonin pour kebano toi tu es étudiant
au samsung campus en effet en quelle
année chez un deuxième temps en deuxième
année alors qu'est ce qui te remets au
sein de son caucus au parcours un peu en
gros le parcours alors moi je suis suis
suisse je suis de loin
en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est que
quand j'étais au lycée je veux un peu
foutu ma cave en l'air parce que j'étais
jeune je pensais qu'elle joue aux jeux
vidéo
ouais et pour ça va pas trop dérangé à
l'époque ce que je vais vite retrouver
un travail derrière mais je savais que
le travail que je faisais chez les
secrétaires médicales
ça me plaisait pas trop enfin c'était
pas ça que j'ai car toute ma ville du
coup j'ai là j'ai vu lors du salon
campus qui permettait de de redonner une
chance auxerre à ceux qui n'avaient pas
le bac
mais j'ai pris cette opportunité pour
venir faire du développement web en
arrêter un sixième j'ai fait un ca fait
en vain ok après j'ai fait un ca fait en
pâtisserie ok
j'ai pas trouvé de travail directement
dans la pâtisserie j'ai travaillé en
métallurgie hockey et si tu as des
problèmes problèmes de santé j'ai dû
arrêter d'accord pendant un an j'ai
essayé de savoir ce que je voulais
vraiment faire oui j'ai mon conjoint qui
est dans le développement et je vais
demander de me montrer en fait et m'a
montré ce qu'ils aient j'ai adoré quand
on commence à hakone tout seul plus loin
j'ai entendu parler du cndd sont donc
j'y suis allé j'ai fait les tests
j'avais peur de m'ennuyer à rester
assise oui à dallas mais prenant on
apprend tout le temps c'est super moi la
fin de vie ces jeux j'avais le choix
entre passions de bach ou faire la
musique oui pour moi c'est une évidence
que je veux faire de la musique et du
coup je me suis dit je vais pas
forcément besoin de mon bac ou du coup
j'ai directement arrêté en terminale je
suis parti sur des écoles prix de
musique
j'ai fait ça pendant quatre ou cinq ans
mon fils est déjà berkeley ça se passait
plutôt bien je fais une première école
j'ai été diplômé j'étais en deuxième
année d'une autre école tu es en lien
avec berkeley où on 4ème neige aurait
plus directement via les 62 écoles
privées et aller vivre aux états unis ça
coûte relativement cher
oui ma famille a pu le financer mais je
pense qu'à un moment c'était à moi aussi
de financer mes propres choses donc j'ai
décidé d'arrêter de faire ça j'ai
cherché ce que je préfère dans la
musique en france il y avait peu de
chose que je pouvais faire
où je me voyais faire du coup j'ai
cherché ce que peut faire d'autre que de
la musique puis j'ai passé un petit
temps à réfléchir un ami m'a parlé du
code
j'ai toujours été avec des ordinateurs
avec de la technologie faim depuis que
je suis petit c'est moi qui m'étais
c'est ce genre de choses je me suis dit
pourquoi pas essayer ça j'ai cherché les
formations ou est ce qu'on pouvait faire
sans un bac en informatique je tombais
sur plusieurs formations mais cette
carotte mon attention c'était celle ci
est du coup j'ai postulé samsung apple
comptons retour pour accompagner vos
sommes son campus parce qu'il ya toute
une section recrutement c'est ça s'est
passé comment vois tu la ressens titouan
tout est vécu comme ans plutôt facile
ouais
c'est ma 40 et j'ai eu vraiment beaucoup
de facilité à passer tous les tests etc
mais je dis pas que c'est facile pour
tout le monde j'ai juste que moi je vais
peut-être que faciliter les anciens
collègues et moi qui nous parlait
décembre son campus pédagogique epitech
aider tout ce qui en découle est
d'accord il était vraiment beaucoup plus
axé sur des projets et du coup
directement sa main dans la brancher
dessus tout de suite c'était plus est a
senti vraiment pourquoi ça ne
correspondait davantage moi beaucoup
plus on faisait entre concrètement
vraiment beaucoup de concret oui bon dès
qu'on faisait un truc emploi est ce
qu'on est ce qu'on faisait qu'est ce que
tu préfères toi le cédant dans le métier
de
développeur codeurs c'est quoi ouais
côté logique il faut vraiment un côté
logique pour réussir à com comment tu
dois après à la sortie de tout ça après
ça le but c'est de faire de l'ia ou de
la big data d'un coup je réfléchis à
comment et quand je termine ça ne sont
qu'en plus je vais me remettre dans les
études à epitech je vais vraiment opté
pour cette fois ci je reprends ma vie en
main et faire un master un bac + 5 s'est
du coup je autre mérite avec pour finir
les études ça y est depuis peu plus aux
autres d'accord on voit un petit peu des
gens qui viennent d'un petit bonheur
pour tout ça compte vraiment les
préjugés on voit des gens qui viennent
vraiment dû tendre aux qu'on n'aurait
pas pu imaginer surtout pour des
développeurs n enlève aux avancées comme
eux on les voit faire c'est comme ça
comment ça se passe le rapport entre
continuer à l'entreprise et puis tu
reviens au campus gead équilibre correct
au travail on n'a plus de projet concret
on doit répondre à un besoin d'un client
fin c'est beaucoup plus cadré et après
on a ses moments aurait au campus et là
on peut élaborer sur des technologies on
peut voir des choses qu'on ne
connaissait pas on a moins obtiendront
un projet fini et on peut plus
expérimentés jouer avec toi tu me
parlais aussi également qu' on peut
aussi s plus apprendre l'anglais je vois
patron qui veut travailler à l'étranger
les formations il ya des cours d'anglais
alors il ya des cours d'anglais
absolument à raison de trois heures par
semaine environ par le niveau bien
évidemment et les meilleurs ont la
possibilité de passer le tohic à la fin
donc ça peut être un avantage à mettre
en avant sur sur son cv et j'ai
complètement oublié ta question de
départ bon si je suis pas bien grave sur
les 200 étudiants qu'on a eu en main
animations qu'ils sont actuellement en
formation jamais identifié un problème
de compétence c'est pas du tout du tout
le sujet ça peut être des raisons
familiales des raisons santé
financières etc qui les ont ramenés à
partir de l'école avant avant d'avoir pu
obtenir le baccalauréat ou pour certains
c'est qu'ils n'étaient pas en phase avec
l'apprentissage traditionnel tel qu'il
est enseigné au collège ou au lycée
bon en tout les cas ces jeunes à ce sont
des jeunes qui sont extrêmement
volontaire mais qui se retrouvait dans
une situation où c'était souvent des
petits boulots très peu de débouchés de
perspectives professionnelles et qui
sont passionnés et qui ont envie de
faire autre chose et le simple son
campus c'est ce qui leur permet
d'atteindre cet objectif ce sera paul
mais ça va être super alors paris ce que
je peux dire ce que tu fais ici c'est en
tout cas plus alors je responsable
pédagogique du 6 mai son complice à
venir c'est moi qui supervise la
totalité la totalité des programmes les
sujets juste comme ça alors qu'est-ce
qu'on approche en faux couple s'était
marié rocher alors on apprend à être
développeur web en deux ans et on le
fait en se jetant c'est à dire que on
fait ce qu'on appelle pédagogie par
projet on leur donne très peu d'éléments
ou l'ordi ce qu'il faut faire et ce
qu'on attend d'eux et le but c'est qu'il
essaye qui trouve qu'ils trouvent leur
propre façon de s'organiser brillante
façon de travailler et quand on y va
quand on n'y connaît pas grand chose
comment on fait pour arriver justement
et se diront ces baptêmes du feu croisé
certains voient le projet des routoirs
exactement notre première le premier
événement qui se passe dans le dans la
formation c'est une complice qu'on
appelle la piscine et ses yeux c'est un
terme qui donne des services
pas d'essai des bérets verts d'accord
donc c'est vraiment une période de très
très très très intenses où on les met
sous l'eau et on voit comment il arrive
à une licence ans avait pu motiver plus
et ça c'est juste les plus motivés ceux
qui veulent en découdre pas d'accord et
alors après comment ça se passe parce
qu'ils ont forcément toujours ça vous
coûte un peu classique formation
explique comment marche le code mois la
structure
une fois qu'il maîtrise à tiens voilà un
projet maintenant vas-y débrouille toi
et on débrief ont fait des rendez-vous
fixe on retrouve tous les tous les jours
exactement c'est à dire que c'est les
projets souvent c'est une ou deux
semaines et à la fin du vrai pain en
garde émises ans on essaie de les suivre
un petit peu moi j'aime leur donne deux
solutions se dire qu'on va les aiguilles
et là on dit là tu vas pas au bon
endroit là tu vas pas moi mais j'aime on
va leur dire comment faire
d'accord ce que c'est très important on
a 45 étudiants et donc à la fin de la
semaine les deux semaines on a 45
projets très différents
oui mais qui font tous la même chose
c'est important pour nous de ne pas
faire de théorie avant et de faire que
de la pratique et de faire d'autres
lauréats ont reçu et déjà mis dans un
état d'esprit dans le milieu
professionnel où la suie aura des
problèmes et tu dois prendre à deux des
dérouillées des bouquets et au delà de
simples parce que à tout ce qui est
informatique c'est quelque chose qui est
voulu extrêmement rapidement donc ça
veut dire que lorsqu'il ya un nouveau
langage qui potentiellement peut arriver
tu as déjà acquis les mécanismes qui
vont te permettre d'apprendre à utiliser
ce nouveau langage faute ouais
comment on fait pour s'inscrire comment
on fait pour s'inscrire on va sur le
site samsung campus point fr d'accord on
clique sur l'onglet candidature ouais on
remplit et ont mis en moi et c'est sa
rechute alors la question je me posais
c'est effectivement on se dit bon ça me
soule ont connu ça me saoule de par les
produits et les services et on voyait on
va pas forcément comme ça le lien direct
entre l'entreprise samsung et le samsung
campus où tu m'a dit toi vous ne risquez
pas les personnes n'est pas un vivier
pour samsung
c'est vraiment une mission pour
accompagner et aider et former dans ça
mais tu l'as dis moi pourquoi comment
pourquoi comment parce que c'est une
vraie volonté du groupe samsung doit
être relativement de mettre en place des
programmes d'engagement sociétal dans
toutes ses filiales partout dans le
monde
et qu'y répondre à des enjeux sociétaux
important donc en france et même en
europe 1 l'un des enjeux c'est
effectivement encore le chômage est
particulièrement le chômage des jeunes
et nous en france on parle effectivement
de cette population de jeunes qui n'a
pas le baccalauréat
parce que c'est eux qui au final sont le
plus impacté par le chômage encore
aujourd'hui oui donc ce qu'on a voulu
faire avec le samsung campus c'est créer
un pont entre cette population de jeunes
et avec un secteur d'avenir puisque il
ya énormément de déboucher sur les
métiers développeurs alors le lucide ça
me saoule campus il y fait chaud oui tu
peux m'en fais aussi du lot celle ci
déjà
l'incertitude est assez simple se basait
sur quatre pages une plage
d'informations sur le campus une page
sur ce que vous allez retrouver dans la
formation
une page de candidature qui quand elles
sont couvertes ont un formulaire à
remplir et c'est lui qui nous mène si on
est pris à jean piscine ouais une page
de témoignages qui vous pourrez trouver
certains témoignages d'anciens élèves ce
qui peut motiver certains à venir
quelqu'un on se retrouve là dedans quoi
mais ça c'est un site un peu c'était du
html clécy temps du repas de back office
derrière donc compliqué modifier très
compliqué à modifier à chaque fois
besoin de repousser les pages sur le
site web très peu flexible donc là en
cinq jours oui c'est une semaine sept
jours 5 parce que nos semaines ici c'est
simple on n'a pas le week-end pendant
cinq jours avec une équipe de combien
personnes de cinq personnes de 5
personnes vous avez fait le nouveau site
front office back office c'est ça on est
honnête j'étais nerveux et voit donc ça
c'est le nouveau site
oui ok avec deux projets d'élèves ou des
petites tapes de newzoo témoignages il
pas encore au lithium
je n'ai pas encore ligne il le sera en
ligne bientôt score sera au rendez vous
mais on mène on met un même temps mais
ici on peut retrouver des articles mais
cette fois ci ils sont modifiables
directement sur un back office la même
page de formation elle aussi également
modifiable sur un back office avec ici
un résumé de projets pour amel ça c'est
un réel projet des lèvres on a refait un
petit twitter c'était un projet tout
semaine aussi une telle candidature qui
elle aussi
ici vous avez des étapes de ce qui va se
passer pour arriver ambitieux
non mais à remplir la même pas le
témoignage en beaucoup plus haut et une
page de faq qu'on a rajouté au cas où
ville et des questions et le côté back
office à vous avez tous qu'au décès du
messti html html html psp etc ça en fait
c'est un back office en php ouais c'est
le frère monclar
ça parle à des gens par mois mais avec
des pages en html hockey des jeux
basques pour les animations et le sait
on peut regarder le code ou alors on
peut pas y entrer
on prouve se basent époque-là piratés
non non attention hein moi j'ai pas de
problème
non il ya un danger ça c'est la page sur
le campus que vous avez vu tout à
l'heure et fait là dedans c'est juste en
fait des boucs les et conditions sur les
événements du back office pour montrer
un article 2 articles plusieurs articles
et tout ça c'est gouverner par du php
qui le renvoie faire seul html et donc
ça c'est le back-office que vous avez
développé google ça en une semaine
en une semaine j'ai dit sauvage toi le
bilan d'une formation comme ça en gros
c'est assez fou ce qu'en deux ans on a
réussi à faire
ouais la première année on a pris
énormément de compétences c'était
beaucoup plus théorique
dès la deuxième année on travaille pour
qu'on sortira avec un bac + 2 reconnu en
sortira avec une expérience
professionnelle en sortir avec des
compétences pour sortir avec un
ordinateur
ouais et tout ça c'est quelque chose
qu'on nous a offert lors qu'on n'avait
pas de bac et je vois très peu de
formations qu'il faut ça est ce que est
ce que je me dis mais quand je savais ce
que pour toi c'est une chance de pouvoir
avoir rencontré cette formation
en règle générale toi toi à titre
personnel qu'est ce que tu penses que
même pour l'ensemble des élèves que tu
côtoies est ce que vous considérez que
c'est quelque part si vous n'avez pas
rencontré ça est ce que vous serez là où
nous sommes aujourd'hui est-ce que non
je pense vraiment que c'est une chance
et que oui c'est ça il ya tellement peu
d'endroits on aura pu voir tout ça que
je suis vraiment heureux d'avoir une
soirée je pense que plein de gens sont
assez reconnaissant est assez heureux de
bon et personne ne t'a fait de sous la
contrainte entier vacances est bon pour
les ranger les plains pas
oui toi tu bosses chez samsung ok donc
là c'est quoi ton rôle exactement dans
le samsung campus tous les sl
toutefois si tu es pour être mentor
d'accord d'un élève du samsung campus
c'est à dire mentor qu'est ce que tu vas
lui apporter qu'elle va dire tu vas que
interagir avec l'idée c'est de les
accompagner lors de leur première année
qui m'a souvent très d'antan ça très
difficile
l'autre pan aussi c'est de leur donner
une visibilité sur en fait les qui sont
les salariés
samsung et plus globalement en fait qui
en salariés d'une entreprise une grosse
entreprise de tuilerie feedback ton sur
ton pour une expertise de professionnels
bah moi en fait je déjeune souvent avec
mon mentor et donc je lui explique ce
que je fais au jour le jour alors
évidemment ça n'aura rien à voir avec ce
petit stade sa formation parce que lui
sera développeurs moi je pus tôt dans la
communication mais en fait ça lui donne
une visibilité bat sur tous les métiers
qui peut y avoir chez samsung moi aussi
je lui explique que mon travail
on enterre les différents services et
donc c'est intéressant aussi pour lui
d'avoir un autre regard sur l'entreprise
voit la force contenue sur sarthe ou
encore péter parce que vous en pensez
vous est ce que vous êtes codeurs est ce
que vous pourriez y aller est ce que
c'est un truc qui vous intéressent est
ce que ça vous tente
est-ce que vous conseille qu'au final
c'est une bonne chose que fait samsung
pour permettre à des personnes qui n'ont
rien à voir avec les métiers du code de
pouvoir venir codeurs de pouvoir en gros
s'accomplir professionnellement et
d'avoir un métier ça ça plutôt cool vous
invite à marquer tout ça bien évidemment
en bas en commentaire on reste connectés
parce que on en reparlera du samsung en
plus nous concerne tous qui est vraiment
intéressant mais c'est chouette une
boîte comme samsung prennent
position par rapport à cela d'autant
plus que je vous dis pour eux c'est pas
un vivier de kohler qui les utilisent
pas n'ont pas besoin mais c'est chouette
qui sont là derrière
donc il faut ce que vous en pensez vous
marquez tout ça il donne rendez-vous dès
demain ciao